les cartons ne sont pas encore tous des
balais mais l'addition est déjà salée à
lino et en est à plus de 1500 euros de
frais avant même sa rentrée scolaire la
caution de l'appartement les abonnements
internet ou les frais d'inscription cet
étudiant non boursier va devoir compter
sur ses parents avec aussi des efforts
drastiques à tenir je me suis acheté un
vélo ça me coûte moins cher que
d'acheter un abonnement au tram à
l'année la fac que d'aller manger aux
rues parce que ça coûte moins cher voilà
toujours à voir se préparer ça gonfle le
matin pour pas avoir à payer un café ou
un truc comme ça à la fac pour le
conserver c'est tous les petits trucs
comme ça faire les applications anti
gaspi comme lui plus de 83 % des
étudiants le sentiment de manquer de
ressources alimentaires suffisantes des
pâtes du riz de la purée et des patates
des réserves d'huile d'olive et du
bouillon de volaille à lino et saute
déjà des repas régulièrement pour
dépenser moins
y a pas énormément de légumes beaucoup
de féculents des trucs qui tiennent
encore quoi ça complique les choses
parce que déjà construit ce pour les
examens et si on mange pas équilibré on
est plus fatigué on a moins d'énergie on
est donc ça impacte le
ça n'impacte la qualité des études
forcément les enquêtes de syndicats
étudiants confirme cette précarité
la rentrée va coûter en moyenne 2000 75
euros alors que le coût de la vie
étudiante est en hausse de 3,2 pour cent
au moins cinq gros poste de dépense
l'attestent comme les transports ou la
mutuelle étudiante auxquels s'ajoutent
aussi les frais de masques contre le coc
vide cette année l'unef s'inquiète
particulièrement pour les étudiants non
boursiers pas tous les étudiants peuvent
se payer un ordinateur et on a remarqué
qu'avec la crise sanitaire
certains étudiants auraient eu besoin
d'ordinateur pour passer leurs parcelles
et malheureusement ça a été le cas quand
on a peur que ça retombe en distance
yale et que certains étudiants ne
puissent pas accéder aux cours comme ils
le veulent se financer un accès à
internet
parmi les trente mille étudiants
attendus sur ce campus à la rentrée un
tiers devrait aussi devenir salarié
c'est le cas dalino est la seule
alternative pour ne pas vivre en dessous
du seuil de pauvreté